so there was chaos behind that like
hidden chaos hidden chaos I never really
talked about that but the closets were
just
atrocious
I mean you opened it up you could I mean
it was packed like a hoarder ah but like
if you didn't open anything or you
didn't open the drawer
wow that's so interesting I gotta talk
to my therapist about that what is that
so interesting I think my mom always
wanted everyone to think she was normal
that she was she had it all she had you
know she had class and she was an
intellect in this
and
you know it was one of those Wizard of
Oz yeah you know you look behind the
curtain it's like oh she was afraid of
that I I think we also I think so you
know it's so interesting you it's uh
it's so interesting I um
I had an oddly similar experience
so when my dad passed away
I kind of was very
numb for
probably like about a year like I
actually couldn't shed a tear it was
wild did you go on any antidepressants
or anything I did well I mean not
antidepressants but I was taking too
many pills for sure and I was very very
anxious and you know just like all all
of the things just trying to just you
know constantly placate just like right
just this just tempering anything
because anything that I felt this felt
like too big and so it was like this is
like there's a year and then
maybe like five years after my dad
passed away this is so wild
um my cupboards
the way you're describing what your
house was that was like my house
and um
my best friend
um Emily she had encouraged me to do
Marie kondo the life-changing magic of
tidying up do you know that no oh my God
it's so amazing is it one of those
things where it says if you haven't
touched it get rid of it if you haven't
yeah does it spark Joy yes or no there's
no maybes
have you heard that no that was a
Netflix show right it was a Netflix show
yeah Sparks Joy but there's an actual
book and and they take you through
because she she anticipates like you
there's no you know people have such a
deep emotional attachment where it comes
to like pictures or cards right or like
whatever whatever or like instruction
manuals for whatever I know you don't
need them there's tutorials on YouTube
that's what she said she was like the
row them away you Google the model
number and boom there it is so there's
like an answer for everything so
initially
um brings this up to me and I have
such a visceral reaction which at first
was like uh no way could I do that and
then it became like this Obsession like
I have to do this and I realized that
you know when you open my cupboard it's
the same thing like like stuff was
crammed in there and I realized I hadn't
touched anything since before my father
died and I and I understood that I was
holding on to
what was and I like literally wasn't
ready to let go and it was this deep
Purge of an experience that kind like no
it changed my life
when I actually did it